Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Eigentlich ist der Rasenfunk werbefrei. Aber wenn es darum geht, befreundete Podcasts zu fördern, dann darf auch hier Werbung sein. Nein, sie muss es sogar. Und deswegen hört ihr jetzt eine Ausgabe mit Jens Huiber vom Sportradio360.
Servus Max. Ich hab ein schlechtes Gewissen.
Warum?
Ich komm immer zu dir, wenn ich irgendwas an den Mann bringen möchte oder an die Frau.
Ja, aber das ist doch in Ordnung.
Okay, dann ist gut.
Meine Türen stehen immer offen. Jens Huiber, meine Damen und Herren, an den Empfangsgeräten da draußen von Sportradio360. Es ist mir eine Ehre, dich wieder im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass zu haben.
Es ist mir eine ganz, ganz große Freude, Max. Ich bin immer gerne hier, in Giesing, in den Studios, wie ich gelesen habe.
Die Studios, sie entwickeln langsam ihren Ruf.
Ja, und Charme. Und es gibt wieder diesen köstlichen Waldbeertee, den auch deine kleinen Damen, auf denen stehen sie.
Absolut, der Waldbeertee ist, wie meine Generation sagt, der Illshit.
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich bin nicht deine Generation. Ich bin, glaube ich, zwei Generationen älter.
Ach, Quatsch, Quatsch. Jens, bevor wir darüber sprechen, was du gemacht hast, für die drei Hörerinnen und Hörer, die dich noch nicht kennen, sag uns kurz, was machst du denn?
Was mache ich mit Sportradio360? Du kannst das auch allgemein beantwortlich mit antworten. Allgemein finde ich das nicht ganz so spannend, aber Sportradio360 ist ein bisschen anders als der Rasenfunk orientiert, weil wir uns eben nicht nur um den Fußball kümmern. Wir sind nicht so tief drin wie der Max. Das höre ich immer wieder. Wahnsinn, wie gut der Max vorbereitet ist. Bei uns ist mehr so der Flow, aber wir schauen immer auch auf andere Sportarten, auf Tennis, auf Motorsport, auf OS-Sport vor allen Dingen auch. Aber natürlich, der Fußball kommt nicht zu kurz. Der steht bei uns auch immer vorne. Aber wir haben eben Leute wie Michael Körner, der öfter dabei ist, wo wir mit der BBL sprechen, Markus Götz über den Handball, Eishockey. Es ist ein bunter Themenmix und ein bisschen auch, Max, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei dir ist, inwieweit du dich zurückhalten kannst als sympathisantes FC Bayern München. Aber bei uns ist es schon ein starkes Meinungsradio. Und deswegen ist der es kaputte Gammasturm Graz oft und prominent vertreten.
Ja, allerdings. Und es ist so ein bisschen, allein jetzt schon bei den paar Namen, die du genannt hast, ist mir wieder aufgefallen, wenn man die Big Show regelmäßig hört. Und ich höre sie jetzt, glaube ich, seit drei Jahren, glaube ich. Jeweils komplett. Also Donnerstag Nachmittag wird runtergeladen. Und oft bin ich am Freitagmittag fertig, weil es ja die Vorbereitung aufs Wochenende ist. Allerdings auch mit leicht erhöhter Geschwindigkeit. 1,7 ist es, glaube ich, bei dir. Nur bei Alexi Menü muss ich immer runterstellen. Den versteht man nämlich sonst nicht mehr. Der wird immer auf 1,5 runtergedrosselt.
Alexi, unser lieber Freund, ein der Vorsitzende des Pep Guardiola-Fan-Clubs, wie wir alle wissen.
Ja gut, wobei da streiten sich manche bei Twitter noch drum. Also Pep Guardiola hat ja viele Fans. Das stimmt. Aber was ich sagen wollte, ist, dass es tatsächlich so ist, du hast wahnsinnig viele Gäste und sehr, sehr tolle Gäste. Und das, was du sagst mit der mangelnden Vorbereitung, das ist natürlich understatement, weil die Gäste sind, wie bei Rasenfunk auch, sind das da. Wir sind quasi nur die, die die Fäden zusammenhalten, was auch irgendwie nicht immer so einfach ist, aber die Gäste machen es aus. Und da ist es bei dir inzwischen wie bei einer guten Serie, so wie bei den Simpsons zum Beispiel, wo es dann den Hausmeister Willi gibt und wo es Mr. Burns gibt. Und man freut sich immer wieder in unterschiedlichen Zusammensetzungen, diese bekannten Gesichter und Stimmen zu hören, mit ihrer jeweiligen Meinung dann auch. Du hast recht, meinungsstärker, vielleicht auch als der Rasenfunk. Aber ich mag das total gerne. Und für mich ist das auch immer so ein bisschen die entscheidende Frage, wen hat er denn jetzt wieder in den einzelnen Segmenten? Also außer Motorsport da ist es ein guter Ort.
Motorsport haben wir ja sehr, sehr oft die gleiche Runde. Aber in der aktuellen Ausgabe von der Big Show bei Sportradio360 ist Olli Seidler da von Sky. Und Olli ist halt wahnsinnig tief drin, zum Beispiel in Hannover. Also er lebt in Hannover, er war für Werder Bremen, wenn ich es richtig auf dem Zettel habe, mal sogar Stadionsprecher. Er kennt sich in Wolfsburg extrem gut aus. Und deswegen, wenn Olli dabei ist, natürlich haben wir über die Champions League gesprochen, natürlich auch über den FC Bayern München. Aber wenn Olli da ist, dann schauen wir auf Wolfsburg. Wenn Michael Born von Sky dabei ist, ein bisschen Hamburg. Marcel Meinhardt ist ja auch ein großer Freund, der Hamburger. Und so versuchen wir das halt irgendwie zu arrangieren, wie du weißt. Und wer halt immer dabei ist, ist der große Maner. Wenn du schon sagst Hausmeister Willi, also der Mann, der bei uns immer alles bremst, ist Andreas Renner.
Der Punkt ist doch.
Aber der Andreas ist ein Mann der ersten Stunde. Wir haben 2011 begonnen mit Gaub, mit Krawinkel und mit Körn. Und der Andreas ist dann relativ schnell dabei. Und ich hab's dir, du weißt das. Andreas Renner hat das goldene Telefonbuch, wo alle Adressen drinstehen und wenn du was brauchst. Ich glaube, er wartet auch auf deinen Anruf. Ich glaube, es würde ihn adeln, wenn er auch mal beim Rasenfunk plaudern dürfte.
Die Adelung wäre ja andersrum zu vergeben. Dann machen wir das definitiv mal. Man möchte ja so viel beschäftigte Menschen immer nicht noch mit einem 3-Stunden-Format treffen. Das ist ein sehr wertvoller Hinweis. Also liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn euch nicht nur Fußball interessiert und ihr aber vielleicht wegen des Fußballs nicht so viel Zeit habt, in die anderen Sportarten reinzublicken, dann ist die Big Show perfekt. Also unglaublich, wieviel ich über die australische Motortourenwagen-Meisterschaft weiß.
Ich habe noch keine Minute gesehen, aber Stefan Heinrich preist sie jedes Mal an. Und ganz, ganz toll muss das sein. Und wenn der in der DTM mitfahren würde, dieser eine Fahrer, wo ich ihn nahm und später vergessen habe, das wäre großartig.
Genau. Und dann auch eine Abgrenzung zur DTM. Ich werde langsam zum NASCAR-Fan, obwohl ich das immer wahnsinnig langweilig fand. Aber man versteht jetzt langsam die Hintergründe und man lernt, das wertzuschätzen. Ich interessiere mich viel mehr für Tennis, als ich es normalerweise tun würde. Wer spricht für dich? Skisport. Ich hätte schon irgendwann mitbekommen, dass Michaele Schifrin alles in Grund und Boden fährt. Jetzt weiß ich aber warum, weil sie die Kraft hat, auch noch unten am Hang in ihrer Position zu bleiben. In jeder Schneelage, egal ob eisig oder matschig und so weiter und so fort. Und so ist das bei so vielen Sportarten. Ich habe über Rugby schon viel, viel mehr gewusst, bevor es jetzt en vogue wurde, auf einmal was über Rugby zu wissen. Also das ist wirklich, finde ich, die beste Adresse, wo man einmal kompakt in der Kompaktheit, wie wir sie kompakt nennen, 3,5 Stunden, auf alle Sportarten klickt. Also ich kann es wirklich nur sehr jedem ans vorlegen.
Das ist sehr lieb von dir, Max.
Und jetzt bist du aber heute hier, um etwas Besonderes zu begrüßen. Was hast du uns denn mitgebracht?
Da kommt, wie Markus Gaubmann-Einkermann sagt, kommt wieder das debile Grinsen in mein Gesicht. Ich habe mich noch einmal an einem Magazin versucht, sehr viele Hörer von dir waren ja wirklich so nett und haben sich das WM-Magazin angeschaut. Das fand ich auch gut, aber jetzt haben wir es noch ein kleines bisschen verbessert, wie ich finde, einfach aus dem Grund, weil ich dem Designer von Andre Vogt von der Fife, also die Basketballfans unter deinen Hörern wissen, die Fife kümmert sich hauptsächlich um die NBA, aber auch ein bisschen um deutschen Basketball. Ich habe dem Designer gesagt, pass auf, der heißt Patrick, Patrick, ich möchte ein Jahresmagazin machen, mach du mir eine Grafik, mach du mir ein Template und ich habe da ein bisschen herumgefragt an die Menschen, die bei mir regelmäßig dabei sind, auch an dich, wie du weißt, Max, und es haben erstaunlich viele Leute gesagt, ok, da schreibe ich dir was. Es haben erstaunlich viele Leute aber nicht gewusst, worüber sie schreiben sollen, also habe ich auch ein kleines bisschen, bisschen so den Hinweis gegeben, na das wäre nett und das wäre nett und so ist ja mein Jahresmagazin herausgekommen, das heißt Hashtag 12 Monate, das hat 104 Seiten. Ich hatte eigentlich mit 60 Seiten gerechnet, aber dann sind halt immer mehr dazugekommen und das covert eben genau das, was die Big Show auch machen möchte, wir, es ist chronologisch geordnet, also gestern hat dich Markus Gaub angesprochen, wieso fangen wir mit College Football an, sage ich Markus, weil am 6. Januar 2018 oder was, der 8. Januar 2018 das Endspiel im College Football war und so ist dieses Heft strukturiert, in der Mitte ungefähr, im Centerfold, was haben wir da, ja im Centerfold sind wir eigentlich brandaktuell, ja sind wir nämlich bei Rasenballsport Salzburg, die sich jetzt qualifiziert haben für die Europa League, fürs Frühjahr, aber eben nicht für die Champions League, da hat Martin Konrad was geschrieben.
Das gefällt mir übrigens sehr gut, jetzt auch Rasenball auf Salzburg anzulegen.
Ja natürlich, muss man ja so machen, sie sind zwar nicht miteinander verwandt, die beiden Vereine, aber es passt halt so gut, wobei ich sagen muss, ich sympathisiere ein bisschen mit den Salzburger, wir sind die Wiener.
Das ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Naja, weil ich finde, natürlich haben die viel mehr Geld als alle anderen, aber sie machen wenigstens was Gescheites damit, aber so ist das ja chronologisch durchgegangen und wenn du Tennis schon ansprichst, ich habe natürlich viele Leute, die ich gut aus der Tennisszene kenne, es gibt recht viel Tennis drinnen, aber was mich ein kleines bisschen überrascht, wenn man so die Themen ausgibt, zur WM wollten eigentlich wenige Leute was schreiben und deswegen war ich umso dankbarer, dass du gesagt hast, die WM war nicht nur Vato Tinki, sondern da gab es wirklich tolle Sachen. Also Max hat auch sich verewigt in unserem Magazin.
Ich bin auch ein kleiner Teil der Gesamtproduktion tatsächlich, du hast ja ja auch einen kleinen Hinweis fallen lassen bei deiner Anfrage, dass WM nicht so schlecht wäre und dann habe ich überlegt, was ich mache und zuerst dachte ich, ich mache den klassischen Rasenfunk moralischen Zeigefinger.
Hat ein bisschen draufgehofft.
Nein, aber das muss ja auch nicht immer sein und ich dachte mal, ich suche mir aber einfach mal die Punkte, die ich schön fand an der WM, auch wenn ich trotzdem finde, dass man den Rest nicht vergessen sollte. Die Doping, die Menschenrechtssituation in Russland und so weiter und so fort, das habe ich getan und tatsächlich sind mehr Punkte zusammengekommen, als ich gedacht hätte. Ich musste noch wegstreichen hinten raus.
Du wirst es nicht glauben. Ich hätte dir aber auch vier Seiten gegönnt. So sind es zwei Seiten geworden.
Ich habe mich an die Zeichenvorgabe gehalten. Das war natürlich naiv, wenn ich mir zum Beispiel angucke, was Axel Goldmann geschrieben hat.
Also man muss sagen, der große Axel Goldmann.
Natürlich, Ed lost in Nippes.
Der Axel ist natürlich ein ganz, ganz großer Red Sox-Fan und hat hier wirklich einen Abriss der letzten 120 Jahre Boston Red Sox-Tippen.
Es ist ein Epos.
Aber es ist sehr, sehr schön geworden. Und das Schöne ist, dass ich mir den Red Sox auch sehr, sehr sympathisiere. Und deswegen hat Axel die vier Seiten bekommen, genauso wie Frank Flige, der ja den Dortmundern sehr zugetan ist. Und der Frank hat so ein bisschen einen Abriss geliefert. Was ist denn passiert zwischen der Zeit von Peter Stöger oder die letzten Monate Stöger, wo in Dortmund, glaube ich, keine besonders tolle Stimmung war und eben jetzt, wo in Dortmund überragende Stimmung ist. Und das sind meine vier Seiten. Ansonsten sind es Doppelseiten, die man, wie ich hoffe, gut lesen kann. Und es gibt auch eine Zeitschiene, die eigentlich am meisten Arbeit gemacht hat, die eben im Januar 2018 beginnt und ein kleines bisschen reinreicht. Ins Jahr 2019 schon endet, glaube ich, Super Bowl am 3. Februar in Atlanta. Super Bowl 53 wird es dann sein. Das war viel Arbeit, das hat wahnsinnig viel Freude gemacht. Ich bin zu Hause gesessen und habe immer gehofft, ein bisschen nachgefragt, was kommt jetzt. Und wenn dann was gekommen ist, habe ich mich echt gefreut. Habe das durchgelesen und habe dann auch geschaut, wo kriege ich die Bilder her. Da muss ich auch sagen, Jürgen Hasenkopf, mein Lieblingsfotograf und Tennisfotograf, der hat uns die Bilder für nichts zur Verfügung gestellt. Bei Getty und bei Firo, da musste man natürlich ein bisschen was bezahlen, aber das war es mir absolut wert. Weil durch Autoren wie dich, Max, und Holger Gertz ist dabei und …Viel zu nah mein Name an dem von Holger Gertz genannt. Nein, Holger ist natürlich einer meiner Säulenheiligen. Was soll ich dir sagen?
Wurde die Seite drei erfunden.
Ja genau. Von ihm und für ihn. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Und das schmeichelt mir auch, wenn Leute wie du und wie Holger und Jörg Almroth und die Saskia, die war bei dir glaube ich auch vor kurzem erst zu Gast, die hat etwas über Robert Harting geschrieben. Es ist ein reines Eitelkeitsprojekt für mich. Ich finde es geil, dass ich da meinen Namen draufpappen durfte, aber das ist wie du sagst. Die Gäste sind die Stars und ich habe es nicht nachgezählt, aber ich glaube es sind 45 oder 46 Autoren, die was schreiben und was soll ich sagen? Ich habe immer noch dieses debile Grinsen im Gesicht.
Absolut und das auch völlig zu Recht. Und entgegen der gängigen Meinung, Prinz sei tot, ist das, also man merkt dann wieder, was es bedeutet, ein Magazin in der Hand zu haben. Ich habe es jetzt auch endlich in Realiter hier tatsächlich in Manhattan. Vorher in der E-Book-Version habe ich schon große Teile davon gelesen, aber es ist nochmal was Besonderes. Das ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr guter Jahresrückblick auch in der Form, finde ich. Ja, lass uns mal ein bisschen durchgehen, auf was man sich so freuen kann. Wir picken uns und wir machen jetzt nicht nur Fußball, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das darf nicht sein. Also, dass es mit College-Football losging, hast du schon erwähnt. Dann direkt natürlich ein ganz großer Marco Hagemann über eine private Reise nach Liverpool.
Darf ich dazu was sagen? Der Marco, du kennst ihn auch persönlich, der Marco ist der netteste Kerl, den man sich vorstellen kann.
Ich kenne ihn tatsächlich nicht persönlich.
Du kennst ihn nicht persönlich.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, ihn zu kennen, unter anderem durch deinen Senftest. Weil da hat man noch mal eine Seite von ihm gesehen, die man so noch nicht kannte.
Also Marco ist einfach der netteste Kerl, den man sich vorstellen kann. Er ist ein geiler Typ, weil wenn mein Anruf sagt, Marco, wir machen morgen Senftest, dann sagt er, was ist das? Ich erkläre es ihm kurz und er ist dabei. Also das ist einfach Marco Haggemann. Und was ich bei Marco natürlich auch so toll sehe, der muss natürlich beruflich, der darf beruflich, das ist ja ein Traum im Grunde genommen, darf beruflich wahnsinnig viel Fußball kommentieren. Aber dann ist er halt auch ein Typ, der ein Fußballfan ist und sagt, komm, da fahre ich jetzt mit zwei Kumpels, fahre ich nach Liverpool und schaue mir dort ein Premier League-Spiel an, friere mir den Arsch ab. Und Marco hat was darüber geschrieben, eben über diesen Trip nach Anfield hatte. Ich möchte nicht zu viel verraten, aber auch wirklich ein geiles Match erwischt, dass es sich dann dort gegeben hat. Und ja, Marco ist toll, weil Marco, ich sage, ich fahre übermorgen mal an Tegernsee zum Trainingslager von Mönchengladbach und habe nichts vor, fahre ich mit. So ist Marco. Wieso kennst du Marco nicht persönlich?
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht müsste ich da Instagram mehr einsetzen. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass der Kanäle um ihn abbrechen. Nein, ich weiß es nicht. Ich bin auch nicht so derjenige, der sich an Leute...
Nein, aber da geht es ja nicht ums Ranschmeißen. Er kennt dich ja, das weiß ich.
Ja, da stellen wir mal einen Kontakt her. Und vor allem, mit wem er nach Liverpool gefahren ist, das ist natürlich sensationell. Unter anderem der Chefredakteur des Kickers, Jörg Jakob, mit dabei. Das sind natürlich Reisegefährten, wie man sie sich wünscht. Dann haben wir natürlich was über den ersten FC Köln. Natürlich, wenn man die Big Show kennt, auch von Christian Sprenger. Das ist völlig logisch. Das heißt, es sind nicht nur vier Good Stories in diesem Heft untergebracht.
Nein, Christian Sprenger hat das Unheil kommen sehen. Das beschreibt er auch. Aber irgendwie kann er mit dem Unheil ganz gut leben.
Absolut. Dann kann man sehr viel lernen über Basketball und auch über deutschen Basketball, also in Deutschland gespieltem Basketball.
Es ist geschrieben von Stefan Koch, den ich über alle Maßen schätze. Telekom Basketball war früher Coach in der BKBBL damals noch. Und da hat er etwas geschrieben über Andrea Trinchieri. Ich habe Trinchieri bei manchen Pressekonferenzen erlebt, der ehemalige Trainer von Bamberg. Ein Schauspieler, aber ein großartiger Trainer. Und Stefan Koch hat da wirklich, wie ich finde, einen fantastischen Artikel geschrieben, weil ich kenne mich bei Basketball nicht wahnsinnig gut aus. Ich schaue gern zu. Aber hier lerne ich was. Das ist Stefan Koch. Absolut.
Und die BBL hat so eine interessante Entwicklung durchgenommen, auch durch den Einstieg der Bayern, aber dass Bamberg da dann entgegenhalten konnte und vor allem mit der Art und Weise, wie sie gespielt haben. Das weiß ich alles nur aus der Big Show. Das könnte auch, weißt du, ich habe kein einziges Spiel gesehen.
Aber schön, dass du das sagst, weil die Meldung von gestern war ja, dass Bamberg wahrscheinlich Insolvenz anmelden muss.
Das habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht mitbekommen. Das war noch nicht in der Big Show drin.
Ja, weil Michael Körner nicht für einen Emergency-Viertel zur Verfügung gestanden ist.
Ja, unglaublich. Aber gut, wir sind halt auch nur so gut wie unsere Gäste, weißt du. Dann natürlich haben wir wieder Ski mit drin. Mit ist der Ledekar, das fand ich sehr interessant, dass da nicht die offensichtliche Won oder die offensichtliche Schifflin abgehandelt wird.
Die Schifflin wird eh jede Woche gefeiert und der Roman Stelzel, der ist von der Tiroler Tageszeitung und der war auch echt in Pyeongchang dabei und hat eben über die Äster, die sowohl beim Skifahren als auch dann beim Snowboard war sie Favoritin. Beim Skifahren war es absolut überraschend, dass sie den Super-Ski gewonnen hat. Sehr schöner Artikel.
Absolut. Holger Gatz blickt nochmal zurück auf das olympische Fest, was wir erleben durften Anfang dieses Jahres. Unglaublich, auch wie lange dieses Sportjahr schon ist, also wie viele Themen ich schon wieder vergessen hatte, die hier mit drin waren. Unter anderem ja auch, dass da durchaus eine deutsche Eishockey-Mannschaft gar nicht so schlecht war.
Und ich hatte schon vergessen, dass die eigentlich gar nicht gut begonnen haben, weißt du? Die haben ja glaube ich die ersten drei Spiele sogar verloren und dann gab es einen Zittersieg und dann hatten wir natürlich immer mit diesen Verlängerungen, dann gegen Schweden, auch gegen Kanada war glaube ich das Halbfinale, ich kann mich selbst nicht mehr erinnern. Und dann diese knappe Niederlage gegen Russland, die, man möchte sagen, auch ein bisschen den Schiedsrichtern geschuldet war, aber es ist alles schon so lange hier.
Absolut, unglaublich, wahnsinniges Sport, ja, auch im Tennis, die deutsche Davis Cup-Mannschaft in Spanien.
Freue mich besonders, weil der Davis Cup-Kapitän persönlich, Michael Kohlmann, in die Tasten gegriffen hat und die Woche eben beschrieben hat, ich war auch dort, war vom Tennis her gesehen schon ein Highlight, weil die haben in dieser Stirrkampfarena gespielt. Also ich bin kein Fan von Rafael Nadal, aber am Sonntag, als er Nadal gegen den Zwerg aufgespielt hat, der läuft ein, magst du, wenn ich nicht zu lang werde? Sag es mir ruhig. Der läuft ein Nadal und das Stadion, das bebt. Das hat richtig gebeten, diese Stirrkampfarena. Wenn du da natürlich rausgehst und aus einen Gängen siehst, diese aus meiner Sicht idiotische Kunst des Stirrkampfs, wie es dort verkauft wird, das brauche ich wirklich nicht, dass da Tiere öffentlich getötet werden, sage ich, nachdem ich in der frühen Leberkäse einmal gegessen habe. Aber gigantisch. Wunderbare Woche und Michael Kohlmann schreibt dem darüber.
Absolut. Also der Davis Cup Teamchef, das ist überragend. Wir erfahren etwas über Don Jackson. Also alle, die jetzt nicht wissen, welches Sport das überhaupt ist. Nein, kauft euch das Heft. Das erfahrt ihr jetzt aber auch erst, nachdem wir gesagt haben, was drin ist. Und dann erfahrt ihr auch, wie ihr das Heft bekommt. Es geht natürlich auch über Handball. Vom Sascha Staat, der ja in der Podcast-Landschaft kein unbeschriebenes Blatt ist und kein ungehörtes Blatt. Absolut. Thomas Böker vom Kicker, auch hier häufiger zu hören im Rasenfunk. Ja, legt nochmal den Roten Teppich für Pep Guardiola aus.
Wir haben auch diese Woche gesprochen, auf er und ich meine, dass er den Roten Teppich bis nach Manchester rollen würde, wenn Pep zurückkäme an die Säbener Straße.
Da ist auch nichts so alleine, aber Pep Guardiola zeichnet sich unter anderem dadurch aus, dass er schlau genug ist, das nicht zu tun. Und wenn man so ehrlich ist, dann ist die Radikalität seines Fußballs auch ganz gut, mit der Radikalität seines jetzigen Fußballvereins in all seinen Machenschaften zu kombinieren und verliert dann auch so ein bisschen das eine glänzt sehr, das andere hat einen Schalenwiederhall.
Ich sehe bei dir die Football-Leaks. Ich habe die Football-Leaks als E-Book und das habe ich durchgelesen, weil ich auch fand, dass Raphael das nicht nur wunderbar recherchiert hat, sondern auch gut geschrieben ist. Also das fand ich wirklich und es ist natürlich absurd. Man muss sich eigentlich vom Fußball abwenden. Ich habe mich nach der Spiegel-Story, ich war nie ein Fan von Cristiano Ronaldo, aber ich kann über den auch nicht mehr reden, im Grunde genommen.
Es ist auch schwierig geworden. Also ich denke da viel drüber nach, wie ich das im Rasenfunk mache und habe ja auch zur WM quasi meine Erhaltung entwickeln müssen. Die Frage war, möchte ich da die täglichen WM-Sendungen machen oder nicht? Aus einer Art von Protest und wie mache ich das auch mit Katar? Und ich habe jetzt so für mich immer diesen zweigleisigen Weg gewählt. Wir werden, das Spiel wird seinen Reiz nie verlieren. Also das Spiel ist einfach geil und dem Spiel kann man immer zugucken. Und deswegen werden wir auch immer über das Spiel reden wollen, egal was drumherum passiert und meine Taktik ist jetzt immer, ich möchte auf das Spiel gucken und auch die schönen Seiten des Spiels beschreiben will, aber das andere nicht ausblenden. Das muss nicht in jedem Nebensatz kommen. Also ich muss nicht bei jedem gewonnenen Sprit eines russischen Spielers muss ich sagen, ja aber vielleicht ist der gedobt. Das wird dann auch zu viel, das wollen die Leute ja nicht mehr hören. Aber hin und wieder muss es schon stattfinden. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass das viele so machen würden. Bei einigen ist mir das ein bisschen zu unkritisch. Naja, dann haben wir noch mal ein bisschen Ice Hockey drin. Diesmal NHL, wenn ich das sage, ja klar, die Vegas Golden Knights. Da hätte man auch einige schattige Geschichten, die man jetzt im Nachhinein so erzählen kann.
Das ja, Lars Mahndorf war da unterwegs, der Mann, der auch unsere Website betreut, gemeinsam mit Kai Pahl und das ist halt ein ganz großer Ice Hockey-Fan. Was soll ich dir sagen?
Absolut, na das ist ja, mehr muss man gar nicht wissen. Dann habe ich was über die WM geschrieben und es gibt aber noch viel interessanter von David Nienhaus, dem Ruhrpoeten einen interessanten Text über die kroatische Nationalmannschaft.
Weil der David im Grunde seines Herzens ja Kroate ist. Also wer David auf Instagram folgt, oder der weiß, er ist oft in Ruwin zu Gast und ich glaube, wenn er es irgendwie vereinbaren könnte, beruflich dann würde er sofort dort hinziehen mit seinen beiden Kindern und mit seiner lieben Frau und er hat aber die Danachklang zu Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft gerade dann auch in Kroatien, das hat auch mir ein bisschen sauer aufgestoßen und David hat es sehr sauer aufgestoßen, deswegen ist es keine Feierstunde für das kroatische Team.
Genau und ich finde, das ist mit einer der wichtigsten Texte für alle Fußball-Fans in diesem Heft, weil das auch mein Verhältnis zur kroatischen Mannschaft sehr gut widerspiegelt, also ohne die vorhergehende biografische Nähe zu Kroatien fand ich die Geschichten schön und fand die Leute toll und ich liebe das Gesicht von Luca Modric in der 85. Minute, wenn der so ausgezehrt ist, aber auch völlig konzentriert und das sieht für mich so aus wie in einem barocken Gemälde der Christus.
Na, bin ich ganz bei dir.
Und dann kommen aber diese Geschichten mit Nationalismus, mit Nähe zu rechtsradikalen Gruppierungen, Bandliedern etc. Das alles war mir, muss ich gestehen, zu großen Teilen unbekannt. Vor allem wie aktuell das alles ist. Ich hatte mich mit den Modric Prozessen befasst oder mit den Prozessen, wo er ausgesagt hat und das ist hier sehr gut nochmal festgehalten und das ist auch so das perfekte Beispiel dafür, dass du kannst eine Mannschaft sportlich feiern, darfst aber den Rest leider auch nicht ganz vergessen, aber solltest du es vielleicht nicht.
Und da muss man leider aus aktuellem Anlass sagen, Kroatien hat den Davis Cup gewonnen am vergangenen Wochenende gegen Frankreich in Lille und dann hat Borna Djuric, einer der Spieler, hat ein Video online gestellt, wo sie in der Kabine sind und eben ein Lied singen. Weißt du, aufgrund dieser Erfahrungen bei der Fußballweltmeisterschaft, die David hier auch wunderbar beschreibt, ich verstehe kein Kroatisch und ich hatte schon wieder meine ganz schlimme Befürchtung, das ist jetzt irgendein Lied, das die kroatischen Rebellen, das politisch in eine Richtung geht, die mir überhaupt nicht passt. Ich konnte es nicht verifizieren, ich weiß es nicht, aber aufgrund dieser Erfahrungen schaut man da, oder ich zumindest, du wahrscheinlich, man schaut einfach mit einem anderen Blick drauf und das ist wichtig, aber es ist halt auch schade gewissermaßen.
Ich konnte auch die Feierlichkeiten nach der WM dann überhaupt nicht genießen. Also mich hat das fast sogar dann schon gestört, dass Freunde, die ich hatte, da Bilder rumgeschickt haben, weil sie da ganz tolle Pyros gesehen haben und wie viele Menschen da waren. Und auf der einen Seite fand ich das auch wunderbar, weil es ist schön, wenn eine Mannschaft für das, was sie getan hat, dann gefeiert wird und wenn nicht immer nur draufgehauen wird. Aber dann wusstest du halt, naja, bei denen auf diesem Doppeldecker oder was die da gefahren sind auf diesem offenen Bus, da waren halt auch Leute mit dabei, mit denen würde ich kein Bier trinken wollen, weil sie auch sagen würden, mit dir will ich kein Bier trinken, du bist kein reiner Kroate.
Ich finde aber das adeltig, dass du mit ihm kein Bier trinken möchtest.
Ja, wir bewegen uns da in unserer eigenen Blase. Wir haben natürlich viel Tennis mit drin, Angelique Kerber darf da nicht fehlen, wir haben Radsport mit drin, das fand ich sehr interessant, den Text von Johannes Knutsch.
Ja, der Johannes ist natürlich ein Fuchs, der war drei Wochen dabei heuer bei der Tour de France und er schreibt was über das Team Sky und vor allen Dingen auch über Dave Brailsford, der Teammanager ist und ja, keiner glaubt, dass es dort mit rechten Dingen zugeht und der Johannes ist ein ganz ganz guter, der sich eben im Sommer mit Leichtathletik und mit Radsport auseinandersetzt, im Winter gerne mit alpinem Skisport, so wissen wir, dass Michaela Schiffrin auch im Flachen raus immer noch die Vorwärtsbewegung hat und den Stand richtig hat, hat Wolfi Maier immer erzählt. Ja, der Johannes, wunderbar, fand ich auch, also einer meiner, wobei ich, ich habe alle Kinder gleich lieb, aber wenn ich sagen müsste, auch eines meiner Lieblingskinder in diesem kleinen Heft.
Absolut. Wir haben noch mehr Tennis-Artikel von Marcel Meinert über Michael Stich. Wir haben einen hervorragenden, herausragenden Text von Dirk Gieselmann, den man, glaube ich, aber auch schon woanders lesen konnte.
Genau, also Dirk hat was aus dem Archiv beigesteuert, wo ist Platzi Krovski, aber wunderbar geschrieben.
Absolut. Ein Kleinod, in das man sich reinlesen möchte. Man erfährt, wie Pitt Gottschalk das Vertrauen zu Spielern aufbaut. Interessant auf vielen Ebenen. Über den Davis Cup, über den viel zu sprechen noch sein wird, glaube ich.
Ja, wer die Tennisteile, also Max ist mittlerweile ein Experte, was das angeht, aber Andre Antitsch, der Chefredakteur des Tennis Magazins, hat eben auch den neuen Davis Cup im Grunde genommen in der Luft zerrissen.
Wie ja so viele. Und es hat ja auch einen Fußballbezug über die Person Gerard Piquet.
Wohl wahr. Und es wird von Federer nicht zum Weihnachtsessen eingeladen, Gerard Piquet.
Vermutlich. Und das ist eigentlich eine ganz gute Moralskala. Wer würde von Federer zum Weihnachtsessen eingeladen? Also ich versuche immer so zu leben, dass er mich einladen würde. Das ist meine Maxime.
Er ist der große Meister.
Das ist für mich der neue kategorische Imperativ. Ich lebe jederzeit so, dass Roger Federer dich und jeden, der sich so verhält, zum Weihnachtsessen einladen würde. Sebastian Wessling, der Ed Flüster Tweets, hat über den BVB geschrieben. Saskia Alleyte, über Robert Harting haben wir schon angesprochen. Natürlich gibt es auch eine Würdigung von Rasenballsport Salzburg.
Ja, Martin Conrad hat das Spiel kommentiert, wo sie gegen Belgrad rausgefallen sind und er kann es bis heute nicht glauben.
In der Champions League Qualifikation. Das war dann Streich Nummer 10 oder 11?
Ich meine 11 sogar schon.
Wahnsinn, unglaublich. Natürlich noch ein bisschen Basketball über Alba Berlin. Sehr interessant. Kai Pahl, der liebe Ad-Doc-Food auf Twitter von alles außer Sport, hat über die Digitalisierung im Fußball-Medienbereich geschrieben. Sehr interessante Gedanken, die er da hat zu Sky, zu The Zone, wie sich da auch die Art der Übertragung weiter verschiebt. Da hätte man auch gerne noch zwei weitere Seiten zugelesen.
Da hat Kai aber gesagt, da weil ich ihm gesagt habe, ungefähr 5000 Zeichen. Da sagt er, für 5000 Zeichen steht er gar nicht auf. Und dann hat er mir 7000 geschickt und deswegen sind die Bilder auch ein bisschen kleiner geworden. Aber wie du sagst, ich plane im nächsten Jahr ein neues, jetzt schon.
Das ist jetzt schon gut geworden quasi. Dann hat natürlich Alex Feuerherd, der Ed-Lisas-Wert von Kolinas Abend über den Video-Assistenten, oder wollen wir ihn Videobeweis nennen, geschrieben, absolut lesenswert, wie alles von Alex.
Weil Alex auch zu Gast war, durfte ihn die Heiligen Hallen vordringen. Alex ist für mich generell ein Lehrmeister, weil er den Blick schärft für Dinge, die in Israel passieren, die wir oder ich zumindest immer aus einer Seite betrachtet haben. Von Alex bekomme ich die andere Seite. Das finde ich hochinteressant, auch auf politischer Ebene. Was die Schiedsrichter angeht, das ist sowieso großartig.
Ja, das Politische. Da muss man sich noch viele Zweitmeinungen dann noch dazu einholen.
Mach ich ja.
Aber es ist ja richtig, wenn man sich in allen Extremen dann mal informiert. Das ist definitiv nicht falsch. Genauso falsch wäre es den oder nicht falsch ist es, den Text von Thomas Wagner zu lesen, der ein unglaublicher Passvorsritt ist. Dieser Text ist genauso, wie er mit dir spricht, in der Big Show. Und das Legendäre darin sind die Dinge, die nicht gesagt werden und die trotzdem angedeutet werden. Zum Beispiel danach Moskau erkundet. Wahnsinnig interessante Stadt, also erst vor Ort. Es folgt ein legendärer Abend. Details unbedeutend.
Ja, und das glaube ich eben nicht. Details wären in diesem Zusammenhang ganz, ganz wichtig. Aber Thomas ist super, war für viel unterwegs und ist natürlich jemand, der den direkten Draht zu den Spielern hat. Der kann auch selbst gut kicken, hat sich leider heuer den Finger verletzt. Wie er auch nicht müde wird, in jeder Big Shot zu betonen.
Ja gut, andere haben sich die Achillesszene gerissen.
Ich wüsste niemand, wer das sein soll.
Bestimmt nicht beim Reitsport, über den es natürlich auch geht. Formel 1 muss dabei sein. Motorsport ist ja sowieso eines der interessantesten, weil Horizont erweiternsten Segmente bei dir. Im Motorsport gibt es so eine scharfe Trennlinie zwischen Leuten, da nehme ich jetzt mal mich, die wissen, wie Motorsport funktioniert und das mal interessanter finden, mal langweiliger. Und dann gibt es die Experten, die wissen, dass das Ventil im neuen Ferrari-Motor mal einmal um Nanomillimeter zu spät geschlossen hat und deswegen waren die da im entscheidenden Sektor ein Zehntel langsamer. Und der Transferriemen zwischen beiden ist dein Motorsport-Segment in der Big Show, finde ich. Da hat man immer wieder den Einblick in diese krassen Details, wo man dann auch irgendwann vielleicht auch mal aussteigt, aber man kann es noch nachvollziehen.
Ja, der Stefan Ehlen, hauptsächlich dafür verantwortlich, und der Stefan Heinrich eben, eine Legende. Wusste ich davor nicht, dass er so eine Legende ist, aber nett, dass er Zeit hat und Christian Nimmervoll. Das ist so unsere Motorsport-Runde, Naska, auch Pete Fink ab und zu. Ja, es ist für mich auch Neuland. Ich bin nur Formel-1-Schauer gewesen, aber mittlerweile wüsste ich zumindest theoretisch über andere Sportarten auch Bescheid.
Absolut.
Ein zweites Lieblingskind. Hast du da gerade aufgeschlagen, mein zweites Lieblingskind, wo ich die Überschrift verbaselt habe, aber...
Darüber wollen wir hinwegsehen. Das sind die kleinen Fehler, die bei so großen Produktionen immer passieren, vor allem, wenn sie halt auf wenigen Schultern lasten. Jens, macht dich da nicht wahnsinnig. Aber tatsächlich, über den Text von Francois Decharteau wollte ich auch noch mit dir sprechen, weil ich finde den so wahnsinnig wichtig. Es geht um Fußball, Kinderfußball in Deutschland und einfach nur seine biografischen Erlebnisse damit, jetzt zusammen mit seinem Sohn. Und da steckt so viel drin, was aussagt, wie der Fußball sich verändert hat.
Ja, und was auch falsch läuft. Ich habe einen Trainerschein gemacht beim Bayerischen Fußballverband, habe meinen Sohn über Jahre trainiert bei dem Verein, wo er kickt. Aber ich habe mich ja selber dabei ertappt. Francois führt ja auch an. Da gewinnt eine Mannschaft 8 zu 1, meinetwegen. Und der Trainer ist aber dann trotzdem nicht zufrieden, weil sie nicht zu nur gespielt haben. Und da stimmt doch was nicht mehr. Und Francois, das muss man wissen, ist Holländer. Also das schöne Spiel ist ihm nicht fremd. Aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass er gar nicht so unfroh wäre nach den Erfahrungen, die er gehabt hat, wenn sein Sohn sagt, der Vincent, Papa, ich möchte doch Eishockeyspieler werden. Wobei ich weiß nicht, ob es beim Eishockeyspieler so viel besser ist. Aber es ist ein absolut lesenswerter Text, weil eben Francois zum einen wunderbar schreiben kann und zum anderen aber auch eine Thematik, die wir Eltern, du hast zwei Mädels, ich weiß nicht, ob die Mannschaftssport treiben, aber ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Ballett als Mannschaftssport gilt.
Natürlich, wenn es dann in Synchronschwerung ausartet, dann schon. Ja, es ist wunderbar geschrieben von Francois, mit großer Freude, aber macht eben genauso wie der Text von David schon ein kleines bisschen nachdenklich.
Ja, absolut. Und das sollen ja gute Texte machen. Natürlich kann der HSV nicht fehlen in so einem Machwerk. Und natürlich viel Borussia Dortmund, also alle BVB-Fans da draußen. Hier könnt ihr noch mal einiges erfahren von hervorragenden Schreibern, unter anderem auch Stefan Butzko, den kennt ihr auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk und natürlich bei dir auch häufiger mit dabei. Der ewige Alexander Wölfing hat natürlich auch was geschrieben bei dir über die DTM.
Neuerdings der Chef bei Ramm für die DTM, ja.
Genau, dann Nicola Martin, also wer dessen Stimme nicht kennt, der hat noch nie Podcasts gebildet. Das muss man einfach mal mitbekommen haben. Dein Sideshow-Bob, der immer mal wieder einzelne Segmente übernimmt, dir zuarbeitet, wenn du unterwegs bist.
Nein, Nicola ist großartig, weil er, Nicola arbeitet sich wirklich ins Thema ein. Und wenn ich sage, Nicola, es ist gerade Schach-WM, kannst du das bitte machen? Dann macht er das mit größter Freude und hat eben da vor zwei Wochen, was ich glaube, mit Johannes Fischer und mit Andre Schulz, der eine Großmeister, haben die wirklich 20 Minuten über Schach geredet. Also ich finde großartig, in der Süddeutschen, Dieter Kindermann heißt er, glaube ich, oder diese Videoanalysen, 20 Minuten, aber ich steige halt nach 5 Minuten aus. Und Nicola ist genau der Mann für diese Themen, ist aber hauptsächlich natürlich ein Mann für Football und hat die GFL, mit GFL TV, das ganze Jahr über begleitet. Und schreibt da so einen kleinen Saisonrückblick über die German Football League, die ich nicht kannte, bis ich Nicola Martins kennengelernt habe. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das gibt, also ich wusste, dass es die Munich Cowboys gibt. Aber ja, sehr, sehr schön geworden, weil das auch wieder kombiniert ist in einem Endspiel, wo eigentlich ein Insolventerverein gegen den Platzhirchen, gegen die Schwäbisch-Hall Unicorns gespielt hat. Ausgang, wer es noch nicht weiß, nachlesen.
Und wer es nicht weiß, kann sich im nächsten Jahr ein bisschen mehr mit der GFL fassen. Es ist eine andere Art von Football, aber zumindest den German Ball kann man sich durchaus mal geben. Das war halt in den letzten zwei Jahren immer dramatisch. Vor allem, man bekommt ein ganz neues Verhältnis zu Feed-Goes, wenn man German Football fährt.
Man denkt sich, hätte ich den nie selber reingesemmelt und vielleicht nicht.
Und dann lernt man, Feed-Goes sind doch tatsächlich schwierig anscheinend. Es wird auch über Mick Schumacher geschrieben von Stefan Ehlen, der auch so einer meiner Lieblinge in deinen Runden immer ist.
Stefan ist auch jemand, wo man eigentlich mitschreiben kann und man muss nichts redigieren, weil er redet wie gedruckt.
Absolut, bewundernswert solche Menschen. Frank Fligge, hast du schon erwähnt, schreibt über den BVB. Das eröffnet auch noch mal so den größeren Horizont. Über die nächste Generation im Tennis können wir von Paul Heuser lesen. Sehr empfehlenswert. Sal Mita schreibt, das ist auch gut zur Weiterbildung in Sprachen, der einzige englische Text.
Ja, ist aber völlig in Ordnung. Er ist ja bei uns auch, wenn er redet Englisch, weil er sich da einfach wohler fühlt. Und ich denke, das kann man unseren Hörern und auch deinen Hörern zumuten, weil gut Englisch, mein Gott.
Unser Englisch kann man ihnen nicht zumuten, aber das von Sal Mita definitiv. Da bin ich gerade schon auch ganz schön am Suchen nach einem Experten oder einer Expertin für Katar. Ich möchte gerne über die WM Katar schon weit im Vorlauf berichten, was da so los ist, weil mich das immer so stört, dass dann alle erst eine Woche vor der WM anfangen, mal zu gucken, wie sieht es denn im Land aus. Bis dahin haben die ja schon alles aufgeräumt, jetzt mal doof gesagt. So war es in Russland auch. Und die große Herausforderung ist, jemanden zu finden, mit dem ich auf Deutsch sprechen kann, damit ich allen Hörern und Hörern meinen Englisch ersparen kann und mir selbst auch.
Ich war zwei Mal in den letzten zwei Monaten zu Gast bei Al-Khassar, das ist ein katarischer TV-Sender, als deutscher Fußballexperte. Da hat mir auch Sel vermittelt über die WM in Katar und habe beim ersten Mal schon gesagt, dass in Deutschland die Bedingungen für die Arbeiter nicht gut geheißen werden, dass es da große Probleme gibt. Und wurde aber wieder eingeladen. Das erste Mal war es im September, meine ich, und habe dann zu dem Produktionsleiter gesagt, die laden mich nie mehr ein. Jetzt habe ich da zweimal gesagt, das geht nicht mit den Arbeitern. Wurde wieder eingeladen, jetzt bin ich vor zwei Wochen fast erfroren vor der Allianz-Arena. Da haben sie so einen Außendreh gemacht, habe ich wieder gesagt, naja, das mit den Arbeitern, das funktioniert so nicht. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob ich noch mal eingeladen werde. Aber ich habe es auch mit Markus in unserem Daily gesagt, mit Markus Gaub, was die hören wollen, in Katar ist, ich glaube, die haben den Eindruck, oder viele Leute haben den Eindruck dort, dass ihnen das der Westen nicht zutraut, dass das was ordentliches wird und die brauchen Bestätigung, dass sie das schaffen. Und klar, wenn ich 20 Milliarden Dollar in die Hand nehme, dann schafft man das und mein Sohn sagt auch, schau mal, Papi, die Stadien, wie die ausschauen, da gab es vor kurzem eine Animation und ganz, ganz toll und ich denke mir, ja, schon, aber da sind dann 200 Leute gestorben beim Aufbau dieser Stadion oder die Leute haben für 3,50 Euro gearbeitet und durften dann jahrelang nicht ausreisen aus dem Land. Aber ja, da bin ich jetzt auch ein bisschen überfragt, was mache ich da als Vater. Darauf hinweisen ja, aber will ich meinem Sohn jetzt schon den Spaß nehmen, weil Max, machen wir uns nichts vor, wenn die in vier Jahren dort spielen in Katar, gerade um die Zeit jetzt, dann werden wir es uns trotzdem anschauen.
Genau, weil das Spiel eben seine, also das Spiel ist gut.
Und wir werden keinen Unterschied sehen zur WM 2006, wo das WM-Stadion Gelsenkirchen, dort heißt es dann WM-Stadion Doha, die Sponsoren werden die gleichen sein und es werden sicherlich viele deutsche Fans hinfahren und auch kroatische Fans und schlagen mich tot.
Vermutlich ja, deswegen, deswegen will ich ja jetzt schon drüber, drüber reden.
Wir fahren dann auch in Max.
So, Rugby, das weiß ich noch nicht, wobei, irgendwie so eine Auswärtsfahrt mit dir, das hätte schon mal seinen besonderen Reiz, der angesprochene epische Text von Axel, wo ich auch schon eine Version 1 tatsächlich lesen durfte, die auch schon sehr, sehr gut war, liebe Axel, ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz toll. At 3.90 kann man auf Twitter auch mal folgen und hören. Das ist quasi noch mal die Extended-Version zum Rasenfunk und die etwas unterhaltsamere. Kann ich sehr empfehlen. Marcel Hirscher, es wäre ein Skandal gewesen, wenn du irgendetwas gemacht hättest, ohne dass Marcel Hirscher drin vorkommt. Ich wundere mich schon, kommt noch Roger Federer eigentlich?
Unglaublich, unglaublich.
Na dann kommt, dann weiß ich ja schon, das nächste Jahreshelf wird dann einfach Roger heißt.
Ja, aber nächstes Jahr wird er aus seinem Abschied nehmen, glaube ich.
Schauen wir mal. Luca Donsic, wer von dem Namen noch nichts gehört hat, der kennt sich zu wenig mit oder interessiert sich nicht für die richtigen Sportarten. Das ist wirklich ein sehr interessanter Name.
Hab zwei Minuten gesehen von Luca Donsic und glaube aber jetzt schon, dass er das Zeug hat, einer der zehn besten Basketballspieler aller Zeiten zu werden.
Und er spielt zusammen mit dem großen Dirk. Bei den Mavericks, deswegen auch sehr empfehlenswert. Der Favorit auf den Text des Jahres, des Jahrzehnts vielleicht, ist mit Bla und Blum überschrieben.
Okay, na bitte.
Wenn Heiko Ulldorp und Jürgen Schmieder darüber debattieren, ob Boston oder Los Angeles die Sportstadt Nummer eins der USA ist, das Protokoll. Sehr, sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut. Aber es hängt auch meinerseits mit einer wahnsinnigen Sympathie für diese beiden Menschen einfach zusammen, die ich noch nie persönlich kennengelernt habe.
Sind beide toll. Also Heiko hat ein enzyklopedisches Sportwissen. Heiko, kannst du alles, ja, damals, 1900…
Die Dailies von den Olympischen Spielen in Rio, das war unglaublich. Nachts um vier, er hat 13 Texte geschrieben. Du rufst an und fragst ihn, sag mal, damals Hürdenlauf in den 70ern, war da nicht irgendwas? Und dann sagt er, ja, na klar.
Also mit Heiko Ulldorp darf man nicht Stadt, Land, Fluss spielen, weil er alles weiß, was Sport angeht. Und Heiko hat sich auch alles angeschaut in Rio, war für die DPA dort und hat wirklich, also der hat das eingeatmet und der war auch bei der WM 2016, hat in São Paulo, WM 2014 in Brasilien, und hat in São Paulo gewohnt, aber ist dann natürlich mit den deutschen, wo haben sie Belo Horizonte, war das 7.1?
Oh Gott, das müsste ich natürlich eigentlich wissen. Ja, wahrscheinlich war es Belo Horizonte.
Steht auch im WM-Heft, kann man übrigens auch bestellen. Und wer es noch nicht hat, ja, Heiko ist großartig. Und Jürgen natürlich auch. Also Jürgen hat auch die Idee gehabt zu diesem Gespräch und ich werde ihm gleich sagen, dass er für den Text des Jahres nominiert wurde.
Absolut. Also einfach, ja, den beiden kann man auch in schriftlicher Form sehr, sehr gut zuhören. Dann Adrian Franke, der Tobias Escher.
Ja, bei sports.com. Also der Adrian ist ein absoluter Football-Experte. Ich finde, er kann es auch so schreiben, dass man es versteht, wenn man eben nicht drin ist im Thema und der hat sich zum Beispiel mal der Top-Draft-Picks angenommen.
Absolut. Also man erfährt wirklich zu allem was und jetzt ist die große Frage, Jens, nachdem wir jetzt allen den Mund wässrig gemacht haben, die Augen wässrig gemacht haben, sich dieses Machwerk anzugucken. Wie kommt man daran? Was muss man tun, um dieses Heft zu bekommen?
Steilpass, edsportradio360.de. Schickt mir bitte eine Mail. Das ganze Teil kostet jetzt 10 Euro. Da ist der Versand inklusive. Wenn ihr dann eine Mail schreibt, steilpassedsportradio360.de, dann bitte nicht vergessen, gleich die postalische Adresse anzugeben. Ihr bekommt eine Rechnung digital und bekommt das Heft. Jetzt ist es schon da. Es liegt schon physisch vor. Es dauert dann zwei, drei Tage. Die Deutsche Post freut sich, euch das nach Hause zu bringen.
Absolut. Und ihr tut damit nicht nur euch selbst etwas Gutes, weil ihr eben wirklich einen sehr, sehr schönen Jahresrückblick auf das Sportjahr 2018 lesen könnt, sondern ihr tut auch damit Sportradio360, dem vielleicht ambitioniertesten deutschen Sportpodcast, etwas Gutes. Tägliche Sendung, dann noch die Big Show. Alles getragen von eineinhalb Menschen.
Es ist sehr, sehr lieb, dass du das sagst, aber allein die Art und Weise, wie du dich auf deinen Rasenfunk vorbereitest, das ist natürlich schon was anderes. Aber wir sind halt alle Nerds.
Ja, absolut. Wir sind Nerds und Nerds müssen sich gegenseitig unterstützen. Und dass ich es jetzt irgendwie geschafft habe in diesem Jahr, hoffentlich den Turnaround zu schaffen, hin zu dem, dass ich mich jetzt auf den Rasenfunk konzentrieren kann, das wäre dir ja nur genauso zu wünschen. Du steckst ja nicht weniger Zeit rein.
Das mache ich. Ja, würde ich gerne machen. Also ich sage, wie es ist. Ich bin auch noch gerne Journalist. Ich war gern zu Tennisturnieren und war bei den ADP-Finals. Jetzt schreibe für tennisnet.com. Das macht mir schon auch noch Spaß. Aber natürlich, wenn ich von meiner Podcasterei leben könnte. Und ich muss sagen, ich war im Sommer schon bei dir. Und es haben von dir sehr, sehr viele nette Hörer.
Und sicher auch Hörerinnen?
Auch Hörerinnen, ja, auch aus Bremen. Liebe Grüße. Und sehr, sehr nett. Und zwei, drei Leute haben auch sich dafür entschieden, auch mich zu unterstützen. Aber natürlich möchte ich von dir nichts wegnehmen. Ich mache es auch, wenn ich nichts bekomme, weil ich einfach ein Nerd bin. Aber natürlich, wie du sagst.
Ja, aber da steckt so viel Arbeit drin. Also da musst du auf jeden Fall was dafür bekommen und zu dem Punkt wegnehmen. So sollten wir gar nicht auf die Welt blicken. Weil wenn jemand jetzt Sportradio360 hört und dann feststellt, das interessiert mich noch mehr als das, was ich im Rasenfunk bekomme, dann ist es doch völlig okay. Also dann hätte ich ja auch gar keine Chance, denjenigen zurückzubekommen und das ist ja auch nicht schlimm, weil ich mache den Rasenfunk so, wie ich das gerne hätte. Und du machst Sportradio360. Deswegen, ich verstehe, also ich kann es nachvollziehen, warum es so ein Konkurrenzdenken bei vielen, die etwa die Herzblut in ihre Sache stecken, gibt. Weil man eben irgendwie dann schon eine Form der Anerkennung dafür bekommen möchte. Man möchte es nicht für drei Leute machen, sondern man freut sich, wenn es 300 oder 3000 Leute sind. Aber ich finde nicht, dass wir Podcasts für uns irgendjemanden wegnehmen. Und wenn jemand lieber 390 hört, oder jemand lieber Fußball-MML hört, oder den Phrasen mehr oder was auch immer, dann soll der oder diejenige das doch bitte gerne einfach machen.
Wir machen es ja genauso. Ich höre die Dan Lebertage-Show an, auf ESPN. Ehe viel zu selten, weil ich keine Zeit habe. Aber wenn, dann ist das halt die Show, die ich mir rausgesucht habe, weil mir die Thematik gut passt, weil mir die Stimmung im Studio gut passt. Und ich sehe bei uns, also zwischen uns beiden, sowieso keine Konkurrenz, weil du ja was ganz anderes machst als ich. Also wirklich, du, das ist top vorbereitet und bei mir geht es kreuz und quer und ich habe auch gar nicht...
Ja, aber dafür hat er alles bei dir, weißt du? Das ist ja der Mehrwert, den man dann bei dir bekommt. Man kann in alles so eintauchen. Und zwar ohne 15 Sendungen hören zu müssen, die jeweils eine Stunde dauern oder eine Dreiviertelstunde, sondern ich habe halt einmal die kompakte Big Show.
Bushi sagt, du musst kürzer werden zu mir, der große Frank Buschmann.
Da würde einem die eine oder andere Erwiderung durchaus einfallen. Hat Bushi nicht auch mal zu dir gesagt, du musst ruhiger werden?
Ja, das hat er zu mir. Wobei Bushi sagt, du musst ruhiger werden, aber nein, ich liebe Frank Buschmann natürlich. Machen wir uns nichts vor. Ich habe sowieso alle Gäste gerne. Jeder, der bei mir zu Gast ist, den habe ich gern. Sonst würde ich ja nicht einladen.
Dann reden wir mal über die, die du bisher nur abgesagt hast.
Sonst würde ich ja die Menschen nicht einladen oder die etwas Interessantes zu sagen haben. Auch viele Sportler, die ich gerne mal haben würde, ohne groß politisch zu werden, aber ich habe schon auch eine klare politische Ausrichtung. Da habe ich jetzt mal jemanden angefragt, wo es mich sehr freuen würde. Wenn der käme, den Namen möchte ich nicht verraten, sonst stehe ich blöd da, wenn er dann nicht kommt. Aber das kann ja dann durchaus sein, wenn dieser Herr dann zu Gast ist bei mir, dass dann viele Leute sagen, das will ich nicht. Das ist mir dann aber auch wurscht, weil dann kommen wir halt nicht zusammen.
Ja, wir sind unsere eigenen Chefredakteurinnen, mit allen positiven und negativen Konsequenzen, die das hat und müssen einfach nur gucken, dass wir nicht zu sehr off the record gehen. Aber dann muss ich noch eine Frage stellen. Freddy Brobic war jetzt im Phrasenmeer. Das ist dieses Springer-Podcast-Ezeugnis. Und jetzt weiß ich natürlich, dass der Pressesprecher von Eintracht Frankfurt, verantwortlich für die Medienkontakte mit Mark Hindelang, ein besonderer Freund von Sportradio360, ist, der auch hier vertreten ist, der einen tollen Text geschrieben hat über eben genau diese Mission Gold der deutschen Eishockey-Nationalmannschaft. Dass Mark Hindelang mir während der WM eine Absage für Freddy Brobic geschickt hat, das war zu erwarten und sie war in einer Höflichkeit formuliert, wie ich ehrlich gesagt selten Absagen bekomme. Meistens ist es kürzer und formloser. Aber wie kann es sein, dass Freddy Brobic dort zu Gast ist und nicht bei dir vier Stunden?
Ich habe Freddy Brobic für diese Woche angefragt, bei Mark. Mark hat gesagt, okay, schaut nicht schlecht aus. Und dann sehe ich dieses Bild, das Freddy Brobic getweetet hat, beim Phrasenmeer. Und wir hoffen, dass Freddy in einer der nächsten Wochen kommen könnte zu uns, aber natürlich dann per Telefon. Jetzt hat mir allerdings einer meiner Hörer, nämlich Christoph Gens, Christoph Peintinger getroffen, den Co-Trainer von Adi Hütter. Und Peintinger hat bei Sturm Graz gespielt.
Oh, das heißt, Freddy Brobic ist raus?
Nein, er ist nicht raus. Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich habe nicht genug. Nein, Freddy Brobic würde mich natürlich sehr, sehr freuen. Und wir hoffen, dass er das nächste Woche zustande kommt. Ich habe jetzt mein Handy im Auto liegen lassen, hätte ich es dir gezeigt. Ich bin in ständigem Austausch mit Mark Hindelang, den ich auch sehr, sehr schätze, weil Mark natürlich ein unfassbarer Sportfan ist, auch als Vizepräsident des Deutschen Eishockey Bundes. Natürlich auch dieser Sportart verbunden. Wir sehen an Freddy Brobic dran und das würde mich sehr freuen, weil ich den auch komplett unterschätzt habe. Weißt du, der macht ja, scheint er wirklich sehr, sehr gut. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Bruno Hübner ist oder ob das er ist. Aber es funktioniert in Frankfurt und das jetzt schon zum wiederholten Male. Und deswegen würde es mich sehr freuen.
Absolut. Er ist kein Podcast-Neuling. Er war vorher auch schon im Immerhärter Podcast einmal zu Gast für 40 Minuten. Die Folge kann ich an der Stelle auch nochmal empfehlen. Er ist jetzt schon der zweite Gast, mit dem dieser andere Podcast ein mehrstündiges Gespräch führt, den ich auch unmittelbar schon angefragt hatte oder anfragen wollte, wo ich mir denke, ja gut, jetzt werden sie nicht nochmal vier Stunden über ihre Karriere sprechen. Das ist jetzt schlecht. Das heißt, ich muss schneller werden im Gästeanfragen, bevor ich dann wieder gemäht werde.
Du hast sowieso den Königszug mit Matthias Sommer und Jan Henke gehabt, das wirst du schwer noch toppen können, finde ich, weil Matthias Sommer für mich, also ganz ehrlich, was die Experten angeht, der größte ist.
Ja, das stimmt, aber das Problem mit dieser Folge ist, Matthias Sommer, toll, es war auch super, diese Möglichkeit zu haben, ich war aber nicht der beste Moderator an diesem Tag. Nee, hinten raus habe ich ein paar Fragen nicht gestellt, die ich hätte stellen müssen, das war so ein bisschen auch Unerfahrenheit, weil wir waren schon weit über der Zeit und so weiter und so fort und es ist auch schwierig, sich der Aura von Matthias Sommer zu entziehen, der dich mit einer Fokussierung anguckt, dass er sich mit seinen Augen durch deine Pupillen durchbrennt und hinter dir ein Loch in die Wand. Also da gibt es keine, da ist es auch schwierig zu widersprechen. Hätte ich aber an der einen oder anderen Stelle jetzt doch gerne getan. Das heißt ja, die Folge war natürlich, von den Gästen her steht sie ein bisschen über so manch anderer Folge und Matthias Sommer und also ich fand es auch wirklich interessant, was sie da erzählt haben, aber mich wurmt, womit wir auch Oliver Wurm, den zweiten großen Sportmagazinmacher, grüßen wollen Deutschlands, grüßen wollen, mich wurmt, dass da einiges auf der Straße liegen geblieben ist, was ich noch hätte dann doch befragen wollen. Vielleicht gibt es irgendwann mal ein Teil zwei dazu, ich arbeite dran. Und mit diesen Tönen würde ich sagen, machen wir das Ding hier zu. Wir haben ja im Grunde, also wenn Leute tatsächlich jetzt noch nicht Lust haben, dieses Heft zu bestellen, dann liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, es printt auch wirklich gar nichts mehr für euch. Dann bleibt bei dem Podcast, dann hört halt einfach das Sportradio360 so und den Rasenfunk bitte auch und alle anderen melden sich bei at steilpass, nein steilpass at sportradio360.de.
Alle weiteren Informationen dort, würde mich freuen.
Mich auch, denn ich kann es wirklich nur sehr empfehlen. Jens, ich danke dir sehr, dass du hergekommen bist, dass du den Weg hier nach Gieding auf dich genommen hast. Und dann hoffen wir, dass dieses Projekt für dich genauso erfolgreich wird, wie die letzten Dinge, die du so angepackt hast und dass du vielleicht den einen oder anderen Hörer und die ein oder andere Hörerin jetzt neu dazugewonnen hast. Das war Kurzbass Nr. 104, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es geht weiter in der Nacht auf Montag, erscheint die nächste Schlusskonferenz. Bis dahin macht's gut, ciao!